well speaking of women that have
opinions I just began reading the
biography of Susan Sontag
and she talks about her upbringing in
the first chapter or the book does how
it's not autobiography but and I know
this is this is not a new question but
do you think a good writer starts from
strained beginnings strained beginnings
and and did she put that that phrase
into context a little bit well there's a
quote as it opens up the book and she
said this in 1987 the distance from my
origins is exactly what I like there was
nothing I could return to mmm so without
going too much in her own personal story
even though she grew up fairly well-off
it wasn't a happy beginning and she
never really felt part of where she came
from
she always wanted to get out even it was
a comfortable middle-class upbringing
that's interesting right okay so the
sorry the question again was do I think
do we think what comes from reading a
excellent writer
somebody who's really able to go there
deep into the dark places of the human
mind and up into the the high manic
points at parts do you think it has to
come from something turbulent like do
artists have to suffer yeah that's a
cliche question yeah yeah no I mean
because you know having suffered a
little myself every once in a while like
suffering is about compassion and it's
about empathy and it's about like if you
strained beginnings or certain kinds of
suffering and they like strips it kind
of strips away a lot of at all but the
mem on my facebook this morning was JK
Rowling who was talking about when she
hit rock bottom and she wasn't homeless
but she was like next best thing to
homeless that you could be in Britain
and she's like everything else is gone
and this is all that
left and and so it's it's easier at that
point to kind of look and say what are
the important things what are the
essential things that you want to convey
what is most important to you both in
your life like what do you want to do
but I think also in your writing I don't
think it hurts sure yeah I'm sure that
there's some some people out there
who've had really pleasant lives and are
also awesome writers but I think is I
think as much as we can you know as we
can amp empathy empathize and as much as
suffering gives us a little nudge toward
that it's helpful yeah I think you know
I had a lovely childhood I grew up
middle-class I grew up in Los Angeles
but at a certain point I had you know
challenges with my father and you know
I'm divorced and you know I have health
issues and there are certain things that
that when I think about where I am now
you know in my late 40s moving into my
50s that I can draw from and that I can
use and mine and we were recently in
Switzerland workshopping our screenplay
and we had an opportunity to work with
an actress and really go deep and and I
realized there were things that I was
not opening myself up to as a writer
that could feed the story in a way that
you know I wanted to be you know I
wanted to keep that side separate and
when we really opened ourselves up to
this hurt and this loss and this
Payne we were like oh that could be
really good and I think because my
background is in journalism I'm
reflecting on other people's lives and
sharing other people's stories and I'm
always focusing that way focusing
outward and this is really forced to me
to focus inward on what really what
really hurts and what really and where
my courage has to come from and in turn
where this character's courage and her
truth has to come from so you know but
I'm not a you know I'm not a drinker I'm
not a smoker I don't do drugs you know I
don't have those kinds of equipment you
know which a lot of writers tend to have
but I do feel like my own personal
journey has been important in my writing
and whether it's as difficult as someone
else's maybe not but it had its own
share of challenges and so I use that
for what I need for this excellent yeah
we hear a lot about people that have a
glass of wine or something else stronger
than coffee you know what do you think
about that because I think for some
people and they say all great rock songs
have been written but you know and
there's there's I think two schools of
thought but then you also hear the
stories about you know Stephen King and
on writing he talks about how his career
got to a certain point and he was using
and he had to stop mm-hmm yeah it was
you know it's actually funny because
when I first started working on this
project a girlfriend of mine who's
writers she's like you need to get out
of yourself drink a glass of wine and
you know two glasses drink the whole
bottle and I thought I don't even know
how to start with that but you know I
get wine for gifts because I'm not a
drinker and so I don't even know what I
really would like
and I did I drank like almost a bottle
of wine and I went to sleep so it didn't
serve me you know like I got really
energetic and cleaned the house and then
at a certain point it just it didn't
because she surfing was that it relaxes
you it allows you to to let go but I
find when I do my early morning writing
you know or late night writing at 3:00
and 4:00 a.m. that gives me that that
feeds me as much as any other stimulant
or depressant or anything else so I just
I just try to I just try to go inside
myself and I think because I free right
it allows me to not criticize myself
because my free writing is just my just
my thoughts and and how I'm feeling and
things like that
when I go to the computer that's when
the rubber meets the road this is house
this has to be perfect this has to be
good but if there you know but I can see
things and my free writing that I'm
thinking because even when we were at
the workshop in Switzerland we had this
challenge where we had to write a scene
a new scene for our screenplay specific
to this character and her mother who had
died and it was Mother's Day and it was
the first time in my 48 years on this
planet that I had not been with my
mother on Mother's Day my mother's still
alive
but I wasn't with her and I emailed her
in wished her happy Mother's Day and I
felt this disconnect for the first time
late my mother's not here and I'm not
celebrating with her and for women who
are for people who have lost their
parent I'm blessed to still have both of
mine but you know like Father's Day came
my dad and my mother were on their 50th
wedding anniversary you know trip so I
didn't spend Mother's Day or Father's
Day this year with either of my parents
and it was just like this weird
disconnect so I tap into that i tap into
that feeling of you know well I was
sitting in Switzerland I was like
talking to my mother like sharing things
with her about what I was doing on that
day and it turned out to be a really
nice scene that we acted out during our
workshop and but it would have never
come that way and I don't know if drugs
would have helped thing like that but it
just comes from my let it comes from my
letting go
my personal letting go so yeah yeah yeah
what do you think about drugs and
writing or then there's a couple ways
that you you tend to think okay how can
it be helping and one is is it
stimulating creativity and the other is
is it working by kind of vanquishing
inhibitions and your inner critic and
I'm not I'm also someone for because of
certain health reasons I quit drinking
at a certain point and so I don't I
don't really indulge I had a and I also
had a roommate back in the day and he I
mean he always wrote his songs smoking
pot they were pretty good songs would
they have been better songs I don't know
but so anyway inhibition or creativity
so if we assume that your creativity is
there and and the only thing that's
blocking it is your inhibitions then I
think it's about generating about having
a practice of being able to kind of dive
into that place and actors have to do it
I recently took an improv class I think
every time I do something like that
every time I do things that that kind of
combat my natural inhibitions it's
that's good for me and I you know I feel
like I'm not bad at it on the page but
then I go out into the world and I'll
you know and I see people who are great
at it at really like tossing things off
in you know the the improv
class was was great it was a Spolin
workshop so not like Second City I'm
being funny but more like I'm being
present I'm being in the moment I'm
imagining myself fully in this place
and I'm reacting in real time and and
that for me is often the reacting in
real time is not a strong suit of mine
I'm a delayed reactor so all of that I
feel like in terms of my life as as an
artist and a storyteller it's something
where I really do try to keep finding
opportunities to work with that so that
I can I can reach that place because I
think we do I think I think everything
is tempting if you're you know be it you
know various substances or practices or
what have you if you you want to kind of
get to a deeper level and you know be
better than what you are
you